- New in theaters this weekend,
Jumanji: The Next Level,
Bombshell, and Richard Jewell.
What will you see?
This is your Weekend Ticket.
(pop music)
- Would you look at me?
I haven't looked like this since---
- Never.
You look like this never.
- I think my eyes are a different color.
- All of you is a different color.
- In the sequel to the successful
Jumanji: Welcome to the
Jungle, Jumanji: The Next Level
sees the return of the old
gang as well as new players
as a couple of old men get sucked
in the Jumanji with the kids.
Things get mixed up
as everyone gets different
avatar bodies this time,
and they face new challenges
as they try to save their friend.
Ah!
This movie's for you
if you loved the first two Jumanji movies,
if you're looking for an
action-adventure comedy
this weekend, or you're
hoping to get stuck
between a Rock and a Hart place.
(pop music)
- Ask yourself what would
scare my grandmother
or piss off my grandfather,
and that's a Fox story.
- Ah, makes more sense.
- Bombshell revisits the rise of a handful
of female reports at Fox News
as they combat the stifling
masculine-controlled media.
And we see Charlize Theron
star as Megyn Kelly,
a role that's already
getting her Oscar buzz.
This movie's for you if you're looking
for an empowering movie this weekend,
if you're interested in
this star-studded cast,
or if you think I'd look
good with blonde hair.
Let me know in the comments.
- You always look at the
guy that found the bomb
just like you always look at
the guy who found the body.
- [Woman] Jewell fits the
profile of the Lone Bomber.
- Based on a true story,
Richard Jewell tells the story
of a security guard who finds
a bomb at the 1996 Olympics
and successfully evacuated the area,
but his life changes as well.
He's deemed a hero.
He is also accused of being a suspect
by both the police and the media.
Damn, son.
This movie's for you if
you're looking for a based
on a true story movie this weekend,
you're down for a little suspense,
or if you're looking for
a little Christmas ham.
I know I am.
(pop music)
That is your Weekend Ticket.
What will you see?
And check back next week for
one of the hardest decisions
between two movies
you'll ever have to make.
(light pop music)